so hello everybody I am sitting here
with Christopher rocky Oh Christopher is
a science fiction author and also an
editor
he has written a series he's working on
a series called the sun-eater in science
fiction I've not read his work but I've
seen him around he's been talking with
people that with Nicholas Kotar and he's
written a few emails and he brought up a
subject which I find very fascinating he
wrote me an email about a few months ago
about the possibility of heavy metal
being an apple trochaic
practice which is that heavy metal could
actually be something which would be the
kind of practice people would use to
kind of frighten the devil or to push
away evil things and so I got really
fascinated by that because I it had
crossed my mind a while ago so I was
hoping to see if he could make the case
for it and so we'll see if he could do
that
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
all right so Christopher maybe you can
start just by telling us a bit about
yourself a little bit about the kind of
projects you're working on and we can
ease into our conversation yeah sure so
I've been writing since I was I think in
second grade I was one of those kids who
never developed social skills or the
ability to play football and so I've
been working on some version of the
story that eventually became the
sun-eater since then I went to school
for a classics and for English rhetoric
at NC State here in North Carolina and I
sold my book series like two weeks after
graduation and I've been working on that
ever since I'm really fortunate with the
timing and I also I work as an assistant
editor at Devine books they're a science
fiction and fantasy publisher the
largest independent science fiction
publisher I think in the
english-speaking world
we're not owned by Simon & Schuster or
one of the big one okay um and I also
I'm also a metal music fan which is why
I was watching the 666 video and I think
you were talking about 666 not as a dark
symbol but as a light one and that being
something that middle community gets
wrong I was like okay
all right and then you described
Osbourne as a satanic stay here and also
hold on
and I sent you an email that I was
really embarrassed about because I
usually don't do that sort of thing I
was saying before that we started
recording
and so this is just something that gets
said a lot about medic music and it just
and it's something like it said too even
about about my work because there's a
real tendency to confuse symbols with
with their context right and my main
character is the book series is set in
the distant future about 20,000 years
out and his family symbol is is a devil
which had been kind of a metal music
joke when I chose it and there is a real
question in the story about whether or
not he's good or evil and there is a lot
of there's going to play there because
it is I guess I should talk about the
books briefly sure yeah it's I was a big
star Wars fan growing up it's part of
the reason I am I never developed social
skills I'm kidding
and it's it's that sort of space opera
only instead of a galaxy you know far
far away long ago it's our distant
future and he I'd like to say he's like
Anakin Skywalker of his becoming Darth
Vader where his best possible option he
tells you page 1 that he is the person
who ended this war between humanity and
these aliens and that he killed all and
the stories why and how it's written as
a memoir and so there's a lot of stuff
that people don't know and a lot of
propaganda he's trying to unpack him he
may be inserting his own twist on the
story as well and he might not so yeah
it's a bit about Who I am and and how
all this gets tied together and why I'm
here alright so now here comes the here
comes the the Cates if you've got to
make for me which is okay look I I'm
serious that I I have thought about this
before because I you know when I started
to think symbolically I started to
realize that a lot of things it's just
when the place that they have it's
usually that's the problem with things
and so I was trying to ask myself a
question like what what would be the
place of different things and then when
I thought about heavy metal I had this
vision of like John the Baptist right
John the Baptist like standing in the
desert and like screaming telling people
like repent the end is near all that
stuff you know he's
he's got this like he's got the natty
hair and he's eating locusts and so he's
kind of like this Martin is crazy
marginal figure the who don't know you
don't if he's insane or not and he's uh
and he's yelling and he's like telling
people he's like telling people they're
sinners and he's accusing and he's doing
all that stuff and so I thought okay
well that seems like in the best of
worlds that that's what heavy metal
could be like any heavy metal could do
that right so anyway so so now you have
to make your case and and tell me why
you think it serves that function well I
I do think I do think that it does and
so I guess before you can say anything
about heavy metal I should just
acknowledge that there are affirmatively
satanic bands okay
and there are neo-pagan ones there are
generally occult ones that does
represent a large sort of vector of the
community but it didn't start that way
it's hard to pinpoint where heavy metal
exactly comes from as a genre some
people will say that it was Black
Sabbath some people will go earlier than
that some people even point to like just
the way that Jimi Hendrix played the
guitar it's a little bit heavier than
others I like the Black Sabbath choice
just because it so clearly gets most of
the features of metal music in in one
band right and for them they they also
sort of steal credit or not steal credit
but take credit in no small part just
because of the the themes they were
getting there Black Sabbath along with
Led Zeppelin and deep purple or usually
sometimes called the unholy trinity of
metal music but there's nothing really
there's nothing really unholy about a
lot of their work Sabbath's the only one
that really deals with occult symbolism
in any great detail the other is we'll
touch on it from time to time but you
know Led Zeppelin's much more like
traditional rock and roll they've got
some fantasy themes going on with a lot
of our Tolkien references and whatnot
and Viking the immigrant song obviously
being about gajala and about Viking but
it doesn't really start to take the
satanic turn until a bit later Sabbath
naming themselves after a horror movie
of course Karloff fell back in 63 or 64
and that's what they wanted to be they
wanted to do horror films but as rock
songs and they wanted to recreate that
feeling of dread and horror is a very
moral genre right and he did all the
monster videos right in and so horror
films are very rarely you know some
modern months or but they're very rarely
on the side of the monster
yeah and a lot of those songs aren't
either there's a song Lord of the world
on I think master reality their third
album then it's done from Satan's point
of view but it's about the costs of
selling one soul right and so Ozzy plays
this demonic character on the stage and
the band sort of backs up that demonic
feel to it but the the message of the
song is don't do this right you turn to
me and all your worldly greed and pride
but will you turn to me when it's your
time to die and the answer's no most
people don't they they you know as they
die they call it usually for God
stereotypically you may be master of the
world this world where you exist you
know which is I've been bored of the
world is one of Satan's monikers right
and but it doesn't take that attitude
toward towards that they actually work
so tired of being cold a satanic band
the second song on on that same album
after forever is affirmatively Christian
it's reminding people to watch out for
their souls if they were just sick of
seeing it in the press all the time
mm-hmm now you know that doesn't mean
again it doesn't mean
fans don't exist but it's interesting to
note things like that because another
great example is the the horns gesture
right that my disease was there's some
dispute as to who started it gene
Simmons claims that it was him a basis
for kiss apparently Keane claims to
invented everything he owns the patent
on on oj the the abbreviation so he
people use that he just he claims a lot
of things interesting guy but that
belongs I think really to Ronnie James
Theo who was with rainbow he was he was
with Black Sabbath I replaced Ozzy
actually and he was from an old Italian
family his grandmother used to do that
you know to ward evil eye off for
differently why onto sunblock and so
what's so interesting to me is the way
that metal miss uses so many symbols or
in the community right people use that
they gave oh yeah you know we're demons
but do in interviews would be very
forthright and saying that this was a
symbol to ward off evil he uses it in
weird times when he's perform it usually
winning mentions that that were like
he's trying to - both portray him and
keep him away like he's a gargoyle in
that moment right and a lot of his songs
too aren't about you know they aren't
affirmatively satanic so much as warning
people about different things very often
social ills right like he is a famous
song called don't talk to strangers and
it's about that simple just don't do it
because they're dangerous but he's in
that moment is sort of playing the role
of the the Fox from Pinocchio right
threatening threatening the audience
right kind of so they are inhabiting
these dark forces but in a way they're
doing it does kind of scare people off
begins yeah mmm-hmm again that's not to
say there aren't bands like I think he's
slightly Cannibal Corpse in one of the
videos and those guys are insane I I
don't I think they have a song called my
house is full of skulls and it turned
out that actually one of them had a
whole bunch of actual human bones in his
house yeah I do not claim
to be a fan of that band I understand
that some people are I don't don't get
it yeah well it seems like the thing
when I when when I listen to you speak I
think that there's something to
understand at least there's something to
understand in terms of apotropaic
symbolism and so so aperture baked
symbolism i anybody's watch my videos
you you've you've seen it I've talked
about gargoyles I've talked about a
monster on the edge the monster on the
edge who's there who's one of his
functions is to protect you from the
bigger monster and so you know you you
have a you have a let's say Cerberus
between the world of the living in the
world of the Dead is the scary
three-headed monster but his purpose is
to guard that that transition so that
bigger monsters from Hades don't come up
and devour the world you know and so the
the the thing about this type of
symbolism is exactly the the problem
that you seem to be talking about which
is it's a it works like it's a symbolism
that works but it also can be a
symbolism that's dangerous because of
that problem and the example that I give
is an example which has nothing to do
which is maybe more political and people
going to understand it better is that
you can imagine let's say an empire
Roman Empire they're being attacked by
nomadic tribes and these nomadic tribes
they have all these fighting techniques
and they have all these arms these
weapons and this way of being that then
the Romans don't know how to deal with
so they're the ultimate stranger they're
they're being strange and the Romans
can't tame them so they're coming in
they're destroying some Roman cities
they're doing all that so the Romans
decide well okay so what do we what
should we do and obviously the only
solution is hire these people or hire
some of these people to then fight the
to fight off the other nomads and so you
do that so you hire the Barbarian to
fight the barbarian and it works but
then there's always a dangerous line
that you cross which is that if you
bring the Barbarian in too much you
never know when the barbarians gonna
turn back on you and then devour you and
so you get the barbarians to fight off
the other barbarians but by the you know
by the 5th century 6th century Rome is
barbarian and all has been taken over by
the very people they tried to use to
fight off the other barbarians right and
I think there's a real danger with that
in the genre just um I mean that's part
of how it has shifted culturally right
especially in a pagan direction I think
that's really metals sort of more
organizing principle in this tent
because the so much of its produced in
Scandinavia in the Scandinavian
countries are turning towards you know
selling form neo-paganism although you
know there's not really any continuity
with you don't feel tradition in it all
made up because I make that joke all the
time I I was talking to a friend's
mother at a wedding and she was talking
about being a Greek pagan and worshiping
Dionysus and asked her if she'd
sacrificed a bull the equinox and put on
a play and she did not know what I was
talking what is it goes back within the
into play where they rip the animals
apart with their bare hands you know my
jaws or something something like that
yeah I don't know I wonder if the
Dionysian people do that but there is
there is a fancy I think just because
people are around those symbols I think
they're attractive and in in certain
ways and that pulls people in weird
directions because there there are bands
who don't get right that even they don't
don't get when the older bands or
certain bands are doing or employing
these symbols aperture pay eclis they
may they may just go all and because
it's loud and it's no easy and it upsets
their parents yeah I actually don't know
if a Z Osborne knows that a lot of those
earlier songs or aperture pay yeah well
one of the things too is that these
people like I I'm sorry to say this but
a lot of the people aren't the smartest
like they're not the smartest people so
I don't think and they're not the most
aware
people's I don't think that even someone
like Ozzy Osbourne necessarily
understood the things he was doing when
he was doing them you know if it's true
yeah so so if some of the things he was
doing was playing this apotropaic
function I'm not sure he was totally
aware not also shared with to the
benefit of his own soul if you know what
I mean I I think that's true I am I will
say though he didn't really write those
songs mm-hmm
he gets a disproportionate amount of
credit for writing the early Black
Sabbath songs because his wife was their
managers daughter and she's worked very
hard to sort of twist the history of
that band in particular if you go on
Black Sabbath's Twitter account to this
day you will see no sign of the other
five singers they had there never
mentioned including do who was the the
next one and geezer butler who was the
bassist wrote most of the lyrics to
those older songs he wrote Iron Man he
wrote more things he wrote a paranoid
and ni B and all those earlier songs
like you know most they get replayed the
most yeah and he was from an Irish
Catholic family and Tony Iommi who's the
guitarist who really is Black Sabbath it
was from an Italian Catholic family I
don't know the degree to which they're
practicing but it's clearly an influence
on their writing in a way that I just
don't think Aussie is aware of and the
older ones will tell you in interviews
right that you know this isn't you know
we're not the satanic been great like
we're trying to tell horror stories and
to scare people know they may not be
aware of apotropaic you know magic for
practices generally but they at least
know that they're not a satanic bent
right enough to enough to write a
Christian song with their third record
just to what was I don't know I'm not a
fan of any metal but what would that
song about like what you said it was a
Christmas song it was um it's called
after forever and it's about it's it's
reminding the audience to maybe think
about religion it's have you ever
thought about your soul can it be saved
or do you think when you go away you'll
just go in the grave and it's reminding
when these things are actually real and
maybe you should you should actually
spend some time thinking
about it it was a point in it where they
asked like what your what are your
feelings about papers of rights are you
you know an Anglican or not or and and a
lot of more specific questions like that
but it basically comes down on you
should be paying attention to these
parts of reality and and and whatnot um
and they're not alone in this either I
mean picking on Black Sabbath a lot
because it's the one that you mentioned
but there are bands like striper who are
very explicitly Christian that's all
they're they write about they've got I
can't remember which I'm a verse from
Isaiah is all stamped on every one of
their their their records the one about
stripes right I can't remember I I
wouldn't know but I just remember the
image I have the glam the glam bent was
in the glam band moment when they had
all the long hair and the makeup and
yeah uniforms with stripes on them man I
could just never I'd even when I was
like 13 14 there was really a lot of
people were into that stuff and I was
just like I just can't they look
ridiculous but they're in they and they
can play I tell you but they did their
last album there was a song on it called
Yahweh that was like a power metal epic
about about God directly directly right
Muslim there wasn't any layer of
metaphoric is usually in popular culture
if you're going to be Christian to any
degree and get away with it it seems
like you have to put it under layers of
protective clothing as it were in order
to make it palatable to people and there
are some heavy metal guys like I know
I think who was it that converted
actually they became like an evangelical
oh well that was Cooper
I was Cooper right he he teaches Bible
study which is amazing right because
he's Alice Cooper but like all the
stories about him you know selling his
soul for talent right he tells these
things because he it's a performance
right there's a story about him killing
a chicken on the stage I was just
telling my coworker about this yesterday
where they said that he'd the headed one
on stage but what happened is
one wandered in it was like an outdoor
performance some fair or something and
he tried to shoo it off the stage and it
flapped away and fell into the stands
and people crushed it and so the
newspaper said the next day you know
this you know terrible Satanist
performer beheaded a chicken on stage
for exactly apparently called him and
asked if he really did that and he's
like of course I didn't do that why
would I kill a chicken he's like well if
anyone asks say you get it you know he
just played that straight but he I think
he had a problem with alcoholism and and
turned around sometime in like the 70s
and he's been devoutly religious ever
since I think he was I think he was a
preacher's kid actually when he was
think he's a Baptist or something but
he's not alone either
um Blackie Lawless who's the lead singer
for wasp which was uh like a real big
you know party you know shock rock band
throwing raw meat into the stands it
there's also like a degenerate line in
the heavy metal like the Motley Crue and
all them like where it was all about
being completely degenerate like it
wasn't the violent like the violent
imagery of Black Sabbath or Metallica or
all those bands it was more like just a
being a complete degenerate wasp is
architect Lee one close yeah they used
to pretend to torture women on stage it
just it just sort of you know as
performance art I mean even even when he
was in the middle of that it seemed
weirdly sane to be an interview so I'll
watch old interviews and I'll be like
well it's just you know the violence
that we're seeing the world and we're
trying to reflect it to say something
about you so I think there is this this
thread of social critique that's still
there even when it's like way too far
for you know for my sensibilities right
and his last album was a concept piece
about the crucifixion and it's played in
the same musical style but he's
completely swung around I think 9/11
really did a number on him if I remember
his story right okay just
psychologically he couldn't believe that
essence the world he was living in he
was in New Yorker and
something about that like when you said
because if if you think about it there's
you know like the The Passion of Christ
The Passion of the Christ by Mel Gibson
is like a heavy-metal movie oh yeah
like that whole aesthetic like the whole
brutality of it you know I you know when
I was remember watching and in thinking
something similar it's like this is
something about this which is about
kinda scaring you and disgusting you and
you know shocking you into understanding
how how serious this is
yeah what I think part of that is is
that the world we inhabit now is so
sanitized straight that getting any of
it however over-the-top and fake and
maybe the over-the-topness is a
necessary feature of this because it
really has to like wake people up I
think it speaks to a a capacity maybe
that some people just don't experience
in their daily lives anymore and so they
go looking it's like it's like
thrill-seeking right it's like people
who go skydiving or something helps
maybe experience the world in a more
full sensible maybe maybe they're going
about it in the wrong way yeah yeah I
think I mean I think you're right like
the way to I think the way to understand
it's the same for all for our movies you
know it's like I don't I don't think
people should watch horror movies I
really think it's but it's it's bad for
you but it's for someone who's lost and
can't feel or doesn't understand you
know the the imminence of death you know
I can understand why they would want it
to see that in order to shock themselves
into to kind of just feeling that or to
understanding that this is a imminent
reality of this is an imminent part of
our reality and to see it's like a kind
of extreme version most some horror
movies seem to be just extreme morality
plays like extreme versions of sin and
punishment you know they kind of try to
deconstruct that into more recent movies
but that seems to be it yeah well
there's something about that in like the
way that Greek tragedies work too right
is that the characters are punished for
their violation of some essential moral
law right well
in in the Oresteia right Clytemnestra
punishes Agamemnon for killing Iphigenia
but then that creates this whole cycle
that has to go back and forth until
finally with Athena they're able to
synthesize some sort of new law to break
them that cycle but the characters are
serially punished for their
transgression yeah and it's something
Shakespeare does to you know to choose
another another more classic example all
the characters in Shakespeare that have
sex outside of marriage die mm-hmm
usually terribly and it's because there
is a violation of that moral law there
and horror movies do that in a really
sort of maximal way and I think that the
visual language and the sound of heavy
metal tries to cash in on some of that I
think and I think very consciously
because I think that's what especially
the earlier bands were trying to do I
think some will be lost the plot like
we're talking about and have gone
further down various avenues trying to
cash in on that chunk factor because
that's what you know brings people in
but I do think it's it's to try and if
it's a part of try many people feel
something something about when you said
about the Greek tragedy I find I find
that you're you seem to be right on in
the sense that my in my perception of
this is also too as we watch
Christianity kind of erode in society
we're seeing the ancient tropes come
back you know because the let's say the
whatever a horror movie can give you
traditionally in a Christian Church you
would get that during Holy Week like
that's what holy one of the things holy
who goes for was to bring you right up
against that insanity right to bring you
right up against that insanity
understand that you are the one doing it
to Christ
understand that Christ is calling you to
be the victim at the same time it was
kind of like synthesizing the whole
question of the you know the the
murderer and the victim and the the
sinful but sinless and
like this crazy capacity to bring all
those threads together into one moment
which is the crucifixion and we
participated in it every year and so it
seems like as we and you know at and
that also replaced even the you know the
the gladden gladiatorial fights the
people killing themselves in the arena
for our pleasure all of that kind of
went away as we had the crucifixion as
the ultimate version of all these
violent threads kind of coming into this
one moment but as we watch Christianity
erode we're seeing all of it come back
like we're seeing you know the cage
fighting and all this stuff
watching people beat each other and also
the extremity of the Greek this kind of
Greek drama of people getting ripped
apart all the stuff that we saw in Greek
tragedy we're seeing it again in these
horror movies and in these things and so
um in the best in the best world like in
the best way they can still be they can
still be a little thread towards Christ
like they can still have a little thread
where you can still use those moments
use those extremes and try to help
people see you know all of this thing
that you're dealing with all of these
feelings all of these situations that
you are attracted to they all culminate
in the crucifixion like that's there you
can't beat that story in terms of
bringing it all together into one into
one story totally I think I think you're
right on because I think a lot of a lot
of the symbolic power in the music for
instance comes from the fact that a lot
of these symbols are appropriated from
especially the Catholic Church the
amount of Catholic symbolism in the
metal scene however twisted around or
placed out of context is enormous is an
extremely popular band called ghost and
the the lead singer dresses as a
Catholic bishop but he paints a skull on
his face and all of his crosses are
upside down and started on the
upside-down cross thing I mean about
symbols being misused that one kills me
in every horror movie and every metal
performance but he dresses he dresses as
a
right yeah and all of their stage
backdrops are stained glass windows that
have you know the album covers and it
actually was at an iron making show last
summer and all of their backdrops on
stage were stained glass windows right
and and and so it's interesting how much
liturgical symbolism is is appropriated
and misused and I think it's because
there is this
I mean eager us all the time right the
West has no culture right
Christianity is no culture of all these
things get repeated all the time but it
obviously does and I think it's just
that it's you know moved so much out of
people's vision for whatever reason I
think possibly because a lot of
Protestants especially in America have
an icon problem they just they won't
look at them they won't their churches
are you know old hotels yeah but there's
so much sure that's been stripped away
then I think the music by using these
symbols catches a lot of young people
and and is like actually this stuff does
exist and we're gonna use it to be cool
and edgy and they use it badly right and
they use it you know I think two
different ends right what's an upside
down it's an epic apotropaic thing it's
an upside down it's a carnival it's all
the symbolism that I want to talk about
the upside down world the clown world
all of it that's what it is you know
like you said the upside down cross you
know it's like it there is a positive
version of the upside down cross which
is the cross of Saint Peter but there's
also you know you're you're not super
smart I mean and use like well I have
this thing I want to that I that I
I love hate this love-hate relationship
I have with this thing and so I'm gonna
use all the imagery but I'm gonna just
turn this thing upside down it's like a
really simple gesture to just say like
I'm making a putting it upside down
right and and and Here I am putting
everything upside down that no the key
the key for us at least now in this
moment in culture is to to now to play
the the last trick on them which is to
flip that back up like that to take the
upside down as it really is be presented
and flip it back I think that that's the
that's the that's the last trick I kind
of joke about that with st. Christopher
- it's the last it's the last trick it's
the last inversion it's the the
inversion of the inversion or whatever
and so all these especially now with
like all these people who love metal for
example who actually Christianity is so
eroded that they have all these metal
symbols they don't even know what they
refer to in terms of their own culture
they just have the upside down version
yeah so I have a funny story about this
cuz there's a meme that goes around on
like imager and read from time to time
about a band called Mao Act which I'm
probably mispronouncing their Swedish
black metal band who started researching
Catholic theology in order to better
blaspheme and the research so much that
they converted to Catholicism we don't
even know what we're doing we got to
learn what we're doing in orders last
name and then just like that's an area
they still write black metal but it's
it's it's Catholic now charismatic
they're very they're fairly obscure and
I think the only time they ever get
mentioned is in the context of this news
story about them trying to blaspheme
better and then converting I've never
really seen people talk about that much
but they do exist and that that final
flip did happen locally in their case
mm-hmm well they're yeah I was reading
and interviewed them a couple days ago
where they were as I was trying to get
ready right now let's talk to you and I
wanted to mesh and this is so funny but
they were talking about how you know
they're talking of the divine darkness
and how that is you know it's pretty
metal right and it might turn into light
you know once you you know or where you
know you come into the fullness of
Christ right but it's dark outside of it
which is you know where perhaps many of
our listeners are so I think this
although it's a black metal is still
very appropriate for what we're doing
that's not my preferred genre of metal
yeah
you know it's not very hospitable to
someone with my worldview but it is so
fascinating that happened that is that I
mean that's exactly what you would think
like that's exactly it's almost like
it's a story that you would read in a in
a short story almost it's it seems so
perfect no yeah that's hilarious so now
so now you let tell us a little bit
about your your journey because you've
been on been on quite a journey I guess
in the past few years related to this
into your own writing and your own life
and spiritual journey yeah so I'm one of
those people that Jordan Peterson talks
about you know helping I I was born
Catholic I raised Catholic and I my
grandparents all died in the same year
they're unrelated circumstances when I
was about 13 well and it was it was just
really hard it was it was a really big
you know personal tragedy for anyone to
go through and that I really sort of
shook my shift my religious convictions
and I combined that with going to high
school right and I moved from a Catholic
school to a public one and there's just
a lot of things going on and so I I
ended up with like the secular student
alliance when I was in college and I had
dinner with Richard Dawkins whoa I know
her in personal one it was like a big
you know Club banquet
yeah I might have had ten words with him
yeah well that's you know the sort of
place I was in and for whatever reason
um I found Jordan Peterson stuff ready
before the c16 stuff really hit so I was
I was in on the ground floor on that and
I I watched everything because it was
just I've always liked the psychology
stuff it was gonna be a psychologist I
changed my mind right when I got to
college because I realized there was not
much money in it unless I wanted to be
an academic for an actual psychiatrist
at school so I thought I'd rather write
stories which is what I was doing it
yeah because you make a lot of money
doing that usually most usual yeah yeah
there you go
good but I am his Bible series in
particular really did did a number on me
so thank you for your part in that I
wouldn't necessarily know where to put
myself I said before the call right
maybe in the narthex still I do know
that I don't really like the antitheist
grab that much anymore I didn't really
like them when I was with them that they
seemed to me seems to me to be very
unhappy I know I was I don't mean to
speak for everybody but it was not a
very like friendly there was a lot of
political tension there to that I just
didn't I didn't find comfortable they
were so interested activism which I
always felt was a weird choice but when
I started I was writing all the way
through this and what's really strange
to me without the book in particular is
that when I wrote the first draft I was
still pretty much in Richard Dawkins
camp hmm and then as I realized it as I
was revising it I was going through all
these personal changes and so the books
written as a memoir by characters about
1500 years old because it's like and his
19 year old self thanks a lot like me
pre revision and who is naritai zhing
the the whole story tends to think like
post post trauma me you know post I
would say conversion because it's more a
journey home than anything but and so
there's some weird dialogue between the
two versions the character that I think
has a lot to do with my my personal
evolution the plots the same you know
the head but it's it's funny because
I'll get some readers who will be like
wow this book is really anti religious
and there are other readers like I have
a friend a couple of friends or a
Catholic priest super edit and they're
like no it's not oh and so people come
away with different ideas about I think
it's one of these interesting about
stories in the same way that you know a
painting or an icon might say more than
a description of it I think stories can
do more
at once yeah that's interesting so now
so you're in you said you're now you're
you feel like you're kind of on you're
on a journey home I guess or you're kind
of in the in the narthex in between yeah
I I'm really struggling I'd still I
think I'm stuck in the same place that
or one of the same places that Peterson
seems to be said where I don't know what
believe me because I don't I don't this
is a really tricky conversation to have
right and I don't know what people mean
when they say that and I don't know what
they mean when they say they feel the
presence of divinity or any of these
things I do know that I the people who
are religious seem happier to me the
ones that I know at least what was
really interesting to me is my fiance
I'm getting married on Saturday
congratulations brother thank you was a
Baptist but she's sort of slipped from
any sort of practicing colleges as many
Millennials do and she was having a
pretty rough time of it and I I
mentioned not really wanting to send my
kids to public school because public
schools made me nervous I think been to
one and that I you know if we had any
maybe Catholic school would be worth
doing and she told me if she went home
to Miami she was choosing school there
at the time she told me she'd just gone
to our CIA van or say a meeting that she
was going to convert and I had not put
that into her head in any way that I
know of but she went through she went
through and got confirmed at First
Communion and all that and that seems to
have been because of my influence in
some way I don't know how but that's
also kind of telling because I'll you
know in in a lot of the biblical stories
women seem to catch these things first
okay so I'm just sort of trying to feel
out what what what what I what I feel
what I believe and what that means I'm
trying to figure it out
are you being married by a priest I am
yeah same priest who married my parents
I you know so it's it's an interesting
thing I don't really know what to make
of it
and so I again this is a difficult
conversation to have I'm just I'm just
sort of waiting to see what happens
hopefully not too long because there's
that overt old story about the three
boats in the flooding house and I I
don't want to drown but I I don't quite
know where I am and I'm worried that if
I rush into something that I'll have a
reaction like I did when I was a kid cuz
I had some whatever reason I just seem
to be contrary yeah wherever I am I push
back when I was you know a kid and I was
religious I handle all these questions I
quit confirmation class midway through
yeah maybe I do you want me to give you
a I'll give you an idea maybe or a
little or a little tip or something that
I think that I think that when you're in
the position that you are and you don't
know what it means to believe and you
don't know exactly what it means to
believe in God I would say that the best
way to deal with that is to is to be
grateful is to thank God and it more
than to see it because Jordan one of the
problems with Jordan is that he says I
act as if God exists and for him that
means I tried to live a moral life and I
tried to do what's right but that's not
the first thing that's the first thing
is to to see the goodness in your life
to see the goodness in your relationship
with your fiance to see the love that
she has for you and to see the the you
know the the moments where people are
manifesting something more to you
you know that some generosity some love
some affection and to thank God for that
and then I think that if you do that and
you're gonna start to see maybe what it
means to to believe in God because
believing God is more of a is more of a
because positioning yourself in life
it's more of a direction in which you're
facing more than a mental game that you
play with your you know with your
thoughts or whatever that you believe in
this you know like what does it even
mean to I'm not even sure what it means
to to totally just say like I don't
believe me it's the opposite like I
don't know what it means when someone
says I don't believe in God and I'm like
what are you talking about you don't
believe in God like okay you don't
believe in a God may be like what God do
you not believe in I'd like to know
because I'm talking about the infinite
source of all being talking about that
which is both being and non-being that
is both beyond existence you know I was
reading some Maximus just now in in the
ecclesiastical mythology
mr. Kaji and he basically says he's like
now on the one hand we could say God
does not exist in other hand we could
say God exists because God is not a
being in this in the sense of the above
like you or he is beyond all existence
so but someone says I don't believe in
God or even when they say I believe in
God I'm like well what do you mean even
when you say you believe in God like
what level at what level are you talking
about here um so I would say that that's
probably not the most important thing
like it it's it's mostly about I think
gratitude and then looking at the story
of Christ and seeing how that story can
be transformative in in your life
because it's the it's the ultimate story
well I haven't thinking about that last
one a third bit just because stories are
what I do hmm
and the degree to which you know the
Christ story relates to things like
Campbell's hero's journey and it is the
best version of that right and and so I
thank you I guess
yes we'll see we'll talk in a few years
and see how the how's it going how it's
going yeah
it's just been a really interesting
couple of years for me in that regard
hmm and so gosh I really don't know what
to say about that sort of thing yeah no
it is it's it's a very difficult
personal conversation hmm yeah well I
really do appreciate it all right
oh it's thanks for sharing that with us
as well and and I mean I it's like just
one step at a time you know just you
just move slowly you're getting married
that's the biggest thing you've got and
so you know hopefully you'll also see
the presence of God in your in your
relationship you know
and that's something that you can see as
well I think I'm gonna see it anywhere
maybe there there you go
gratitude definitely be a theme for the
last week and for the rest of this one I
should awesome oh yeah and so now you're
working on this series so how many books
these are you supposed to be making it
so I turn the third one in a couple
weeks ago I've got two more this is
gonna be five and then and then we'll
see where I go from there I might want
to do young adult series after that or
some standalone novels but it's there
they're not small they take about a year
together they're about a quarter million
words apiece and so yeah this has just
been an ongoing project to try to do
about one a year but I also edit a bunch
of a short story anthologies that work
with all kinds of writers you know
actually there's something I meant to
say during all the heavy metal stuff is
that there is a weird relationship right
between any metal music and and the
whole literature of the imagination
fantasy science fiction they no small
part regular talking about Sabbath be
inspired by horror films but when
Zeppelin's got this complex with poking
mm-hmm and I remember you talked to
Nicholas about of Tolkien's so and he's
hugely influential my own work as well
as I'm writing a different genre or at
least superficially a different genre I
think science fiction is all fantasy
there right in some form or other you
know is the genre dissed arguments about
genre distinctions between science
fiction and fantasy and all the little
subgenres or as annoying and it occurs
the distinctions between genres I don't
it's such a popular panel item at
conventions they're always like what's
urban fantasy and I'm like it's not it
doesn't matter
but lens Evelyn writes all these songs
that touch on on middle-earth and stuff
and what's so interesting about that is
that they ended up making Lord of the
Rings really popular with hippies 16
there is this huge boom in no small part
because my publishers father Donald
Walheim published an unauthorized
edition as a paperback there's some
loophole in the way copyright law works
and he's able to bootleg basically
because Tolkien didn't want to publish
them as a paperback and so this cheap
edition got published and got picked up
by a bunch of science fiction and
fantasy fans who were are who are a lot
of them hippies and punks and so on and
so Tolkien caught on with the least
likely people imagine so funny which is
another kind of inversion here right um
because the tokens world basically got
it
like it has a caste system in it
basically it looks like he looks like
medieval India or something sometimes
yeah you know but it is he's so
explicitly Catholic to really in the way
that that's written and he's an Oxford
dong right he he's the last person any
of these people would read and it
becomes the underpinning for the entire
genre really because really
revolutionized the way we told a big
fantasy series dude where people
complain about it now you've got all
these you know activist writers who are
talking about trying to get away from
pole kinis
you know shadow and his his worldview in
his world building and it just they just
can't seem to shake it anyway yeah there
was a story that went around about it
works a couple I think like half a year
ago or so where this guy was talking
about how the orcs were all this this
horrific racist stereotype you know and
I actually know that guy he was a guest
lecturer at NC State the guy who told
that particular story but he
they just they can't get away can't get
away from talking to keep trying to
divorce fantasy from him so did you try
to write a story where the orcs win or
something like reversed a short story
where he conflated Bilbo Baggins with
senator Bilbo who was an American
senator who was a segregationist
and it was it was a strange like satire
piece III ready to why over that's why
I'm a little fuzzy on the details of the
story itself but it's it's it's really
emblematic of this a way that people
keep trying to trip Tolkien out of the
the Canon if you will because so many
people are aware of the fact that
Tolkien is this religious you know sort
of conservative figure it was I was
talking to a writer a last Commission I
was at and I just I described Tolkien as
conservative in it like blew his mind
the return of the king like what is
arguing about dude he didn't get it and
it's so bizarre of me because the people
who are fantasy fans and war metal fans
to an extent who are rock music fan or
these sort of marginal figures right if
you've ever been to a science fiction
convention you'll I'm always and I don't
need to sound this is gonna sound bad
but I'm always surprised that like I
don't see these people anywhere else
right I go there and I'm like where are
you guys on Tuesday damn they are these
these you know marginal people and I was
one of them right I was this kid who
didn't really fit in in school I was in
a class of like 20 kids all the way up
through eighth grade and by about third
grade they mostly decided who their
friends were and I was not most of their
friends and I think that sort of the
archetype like fan person right um they
might be you know marginalized for
different reasons I was marginalized for
being weird as opposed to you know the
canonical reasons people were
marginalized in 21st century right base
sex behavior you know these sorts of
things
but I but that's the sort of person who
is attracted to things like fantasy and
to end like metal music - there's
something in Lord of the Rings the the
thing that saves and I'm kind of joke
like I'm going over the top and I'm
saying that his world is like it's like
medieval India he there's something
about the the great thing about token
would say is it and also makes it
Christian is that his main character is
the littlest of these like he doesn't he
talks about the loftiness of the elves
and they'll and you know and all these
other characters but the one who saved
the day ends up being the smallest one
and so because of that he fills his
world like he doesn't just he doesn't
just say you know it's like hi good down
bad like there's also this idea that
that even at the lowest even the
smallest one can play a part and
participate in the grand story and so
right in and final redemptions in the
hands of God - right there's this really
twisted marginal figure right so I want
to make sure that I apologize to my
fellow marginal nerd friends you know we
are all going to a certain extent and
and that's that is the way that the
world is right there's a part of us that
is is that sort of you know that that
wretched marginal you know character
so I think part of what attracts
everyone to Tolkien right especially you
know the fan community right it is that
there is still that bet space there's a
little bit left you know I'm not tied
off my fringe right um it's even gone
right the it is the the pity of Bilbo
that rules the fate of money right he
spares this this this wretched thing so
yeah it's it's but it's it is it's this
strange to me that the the margins of
society right centered this very
Christian you know fantasy story
rock and roll helped do that and it
brought all these people because I know
people who don't look like I was at a
party once and someone said that they
had to stop seeing their kid because he
dabbled in Christianity which it was it
was the most upside-down sentence I ever
heard it's like he's hiding a Bible
under is under his pillow you know and
apparently he does but they also were
talking about how they really like
talking about 20 minutes earlier right
and I didn't bother to point this out
because it was late and I didn't want to
be in a party with all these witches
anymore which is it was a conventions or
like this there are an inordinate number
of witches who are involved in science
fiction or fantasy writing I don't take
them seriously i someone tells me that
they're a practicing witch I think oh
right and I play Dungeons and Dragons
sometimes too it's all made up anyways
it's it's all weird modern invention
very earliest mid 19th century you know
yeah
gosh it's so silly but they there are so
many of them and it's this weird
reactionary goofy thing but they are
also attracted to the same stories and
so they run in these circles yeah you
know
it's funny because I'm working I've been
working on a story
like an origin story of Santa Claus for
a few years and I bought I saw that more
Grant Morrison had published a graphic
novel called Klaus and so I got it and I
knew Kenny what I was gonna get it what
I was gonna get you know but it was just
so hilarious to see this desire to make
Santa Claus into like a pagan figure and
to like a completely pagan non Christian
figure you know I think Christmas isn't
mentioned once they always say you'll
tide or whatever and and it was like it
was just so I mean I knew like I said I
knew that's what it was gonna be but it
was just still shocking to like read the
entire graphic novel and to realize you
know he's like taking psychedelics and
he's seeing he's seeing what do they
call machine elves or whatever and like
all this stuff and his clockwork elves
and I'm like oh my goodness this is nuts
it's so straight this is the same thing
though with like misappropriating these
symbols right is I don't know if they're
afraid to play the things straight or if
they don't like the original version of
the myth because they have an antipathy
for the faith and whatever but there's a
there there's a strange current that
they can't quite not use those stories
right you like look at look at how many
King Arthur adaptations come out right
without searching every single every
single medieval movie you know never has
Christianity any which is just bizarre
which is like evil Catholic exactly but
actually they do mention God frequently
in that one never mind
that movie gets a pass and that's why
all the King Arthur movie suck they just
stink to high heaven because they don't
have the Grail they don't have
everything that makes King Arthur King
Arthur you know and the end and then
when you have the Grail and you have you
know the Feast of Pentecost and all
these things then Merlin as a shady kind
of ambiguous figure makes sense but if
you're in a medieval world where there's
no Christianity then it's like okay well
Merlin just a wizard because we've seen
wizards in Harry Potter and we'd seen
wizards everywhere they don't they don't
matter cuz they all wear pointy hats and
we all know what they are but it's like
in a Christian world then you would have
then Merlin could actually play an
interesting role and as this kind of
strange ambiguous character this kind of
marginal figure that is we don't know
which side he's on we're not sure what
his intentions are it's like they're
you've got interesting stuff but without
that it's just nonsense yeah but there's
this weird tendency to just denature
everything right there's not even a
margin anymore so nobody can fit anyway
these stories are so sanitized
especially by Hollywood level if they
don't really know what to do with any of
it all right well it's our job now then
it's our job to tell the good stories
that's it yeah that's the truth I hope
someone you know well we're yeah I think
we're it's it's growing I think we're
gonna see more and more and hopefully
yeah hopefully we can just encourage
people to to learn the good stories and
to tell the good stories um that's one
of that's one of the things I'm trying
to do that's for sure to try to get you
know like even connected people like you
with Nicholas and start to connect with
people that are trying to to tell the
stories in the in a good way you know
even though the weird stuff you can have
the weird stuff just have it in the
right place and it's fine like it's yeah
I will say that's what I hope I'm doing
right to go back to the st. Christopher
story that is my name right which is
what freaked me out about the story when
you when you told it in the video I hope
that my works in some way because
they're not explicitly Christian books
even to the degree the Lord of the Rings
did when I was writing them I thought I
was just writing science fiction stories
and I don't know exactly what it is I am
writing but I hope but some people will
come to that and then come through them
maybe to something more meaningful and I
hope that I entertain people tell those
stories yeah all right Christopher it
was really great to talk to you and you
I'll have to think more about have you
met him not too much I can send you a
couple suggestions if you are
we spend you after forever I think that
one's pretty safe that's the song that's
that song by Black Sabbath that is a
Christian walk
all right I mean I listen to heavy metal
before like I've heard it I'm not just
never been a fan it's not like I'm not
saying that to be like to look virtuous
are you I was a punk rock I was a punk
rock I you know I that's what I was
listening to so it's not it's not a way
to say it is just not just the thing
about them there's the metal crowd they
just also have this like hermetic thing
where the metal fans they kind of they
know which I don't know they like no
they can tell each other or they kind of
have this weird thing where they know
each other
it's the sub-genre thing their main
truly estranged from one another there's
a weird Tower of Babel thing that's gone
on where like black metal people don't
talk to power metal people and they only
agree on the old stuff and even then not
all the time it's strange all right so
it's great to talk to you and hopefully
I'm hoping that if I have time to read
your novels we can have a another
conversation after the hop I would love
to I sent you a copy if you want sure
yeah great and I wish you all the best
on your your new wedding and hopefully
uh yeah a new life starting that sounds
like adventure on its own thank you very
much all right thanks really my pleasure
hope you enjoyed this discussion with
Christopher rokkyo please check out his
books I'm gonna put links to his writing
in the description so you can see that
there are a lot of things coming up very
soon I'm going to be in Seattle in the
month of May first week of May so the
weekend of May second I will be speaking
at the shared inheritance conference
their details are coming but mark that
on your schedule I'm also going to be
giving a week-long carving workshop from
the fourth to the ninth in Seattle so if
you're interested in that spending a
whole week be carved we talk we have a
lot of fun discussing all kinds of
subjects stay tuned to that because
details for how to to sign up for that
will be coming very soon I will also be
in Hartford Connecticut in the
month of June which will be the first
week of June from the 31st of May to the
6th of June and usually the same thing
there a whole week of carving and
hanging out and talking so stay tuned to
that also for details how to sign up for
that and yeah so new video coming up
very soon guys thanks for your support
and talk to you very soon